to outfit number
three I'm getting Very Bad Bunny Vibes I
don't know if it's the snake skin the
neon green I feel like it's a lot but
I'm lowkey this is probably one of the
best ones it's more consistent oh you
won brother where you going the
balenciagas she got to pick my shoes up
with a little bit more respect oh they
not so bad like pretty clean I don't
know if you have curly hair or the girl
you was with have curly hair but I have
curly hair you know I don't like nothing
about it period what
is let me just do you a favor I'mma to
take it
off let's let this die you might as well
let this die too cuz now this is an
outfit like I knew it was outfit when I
pulled up I would wear this lowy